love this
okay this is a such a huge honor to
stand here and first of all i think i
can send student cadmea world you guess
make this fantastic festival and all
this invent attorney in this who week
gonna be my volleyball experience to
include me go further and also also I
once thank my school's University of
Southern California special my advisor
Mike Pattinson Candace reaching and
rigor and Eric and eric hanson filters
what is its own okay they gave a
ticktick to give me so many powerful
help and support and I want to thank my
great composer totally I think Steve
there no he's not here okay I was thank
Mike will composite óleo he make this
beautiful music for me and I once thank
my great great co-creator and girlfriend
fan Liang and she's she stood there and
yeah she is so important to me and this
project without her I think this film
will not be here and I need to sync on
my team member my family my friends not
classmate and my biased audience thank
you guys so much